Going to read something from [inaudible],
which is one of the readings that you have,
I should like even now to stress the fact that the psychopathology of the
shamanic vocation is not profane.
It does not belong to ordinary symptomatology.
So what he's saying is that it's not psychopathological,
it's part of normative personalities development.
It has an initiatory structure in significance and signification.
In short,
it reproduces a traditional mystical pattern.
The total crisis of the future Sharman sometimes leading to complete
disintegration of the personality and to madness can be evaluated not only as an
initiatory death,
but also as a symbolic return to the pre cosmotronic chaos to the amorphous and
indescribable state that precedes any cosmogony cause.
Margariney is the account of the initial creation of being.
So in the Judeo Christian tradition,
for example,
that would be the emergence of order out of the initial state of chaos.
That's,
that's produced by God's word.
So,
and that's another symbolic representation.
There's chaos,
there's the active word and there's order.
And those are the three initial elements of being.
And so the Shaman in some senses reducing himself as a consequence of exposure
to something radical to the initial components of his being and then being
reconstructed out of that.
And that happens to you all the time.
In some sense when you encounter an obstacle that really sets you back because
you know you've ordered the world and then what you find out is the ordering of
the world is incorrect and before you can reorder it has to become chaotic.
It does become chaotic.
That's what sets you back.
And then out of that chaos you have to bring out a new order if you can,
you know.
So for example,
you get betrayed by someone that you love.
It's like,
okay,
it's time to update your world model now can you?
Well maybe not,
you know,
because if you really update it,
you have to come.
You have to come to terms with the fact that that individual,
which would also include you,
is capable of radically immoral act because betrayal is a radically immoral,
moral locked,
right?
If there's any thing that's actually a moral,
it's people telling you one thing and then doing a whole bunch of other things
behind your back.
And then that brings up a question,
which is,
well,
how the hell can people be like that?
Especially because I'm also a person.
And then also how can I be so naive and moronic that that can happen to me?
So,
and those are not trivial questions.
You know,
if you can't,
if you don't have an answer to them at hand,
what it means is that there's half the world you haven't mapped out,
which would be the negative half.
And you may have to revisit and revise and destroy virtually all of your
assumptions about the world.
So that's a reduction to chaos.
It is not fun,
especially if it happens accidentally and it can be traumatic enough so you
never recover from it.
Post traumatic stress disorders like that.
Like if you watch soldiers in battle and they get post traumatic stress
disorder,
it's very frequent that they get it because something they did not because of
something that happened to them,
you know,
so they're out on a mission of some sort and they shoot a three year old child.
It's like,
and maybe they do it consciously and then,
you know,
they wake up after they do it and they think,
well that's not me.
It's like,
Oh yes it is.
It's just not the you that you think you are and the you that did that man in
countering,
that's going to be enough to damage your consciousness.
And that is what happened to people with post traumatic stress disorder.
Like it blows them apart so badly and not just psychologically right.
It,
it radically alters them physiologically their amygdalas grow in their
hippocampus by shrink.
If you have post traumatic stress disorder,
it's a whole brain transformation.
It's like it's no joke.
And the human capacity for evil is so deep that,
well young,
for example,
he thought that that uh,
you know,
an accidental encounter with it.
It was enough to well enough to lead to madness in some cases,
and it's,
it's no joke.